- AMD's RX 6950 XT is almost
a totally different class
of GPU compared to when it first launched
to tepid reviews earlier this year.
And with recent price adjustments,
it is such a good deal now
that its green opponent
no longer makes any sense
and neither does its
predecessor, the 6900 XT.
But why am I talking
about the 6000 Series?
Because however the RX
7900 Series performs today,
and it's good,
I want you to also keep
in mind AMD's track record
for dramatically improving the performance
of their GPUs through new
features and driver optimizations.
Personally, I'm counting on it
because now that I have publicly committed
to skipping NVIDIA's
latest 40 series cards,
AMD is my only hope for an
upgrade this generation,
just like my only hope of paying
our production team is our sponsor.
- PDQ. Automate patch management
and software updates with PDQ.
Search your library of over 200 ready
to deploy applications
and install software zero
touch from your desk.
Start your free trial at pdq.com/ltt.
(upbeat music)
- Right out of the gate,
the 7900 Series is full of upgrades.
It features AMD's brand
new RDNA 3 architecture,
up to 24 gigabytes of
much higher bandwidth,
GDDR6 memory, substantially
boosted core clocks
across the board, and this is great,
the step down 7900 XT comes
with as many compute units
as AMD's previous flagship
with the beefier XTX rocking even more.
Despite having more and
faster cores though,
one of AMD's boldest claims is
that they've managed to
improve efficiency by 54%.
This is thanks in large part
to AMD's high bandwidth chiplets design,
the first of its kind in a modern GPU.
What's more, they've beefed
up their ray accelerator cores
for real-time raytrace
lighting in supported games
and finally included AI
accelerator cores to bring Radeon
to feature parity with
NVIDIA and Intel's offerings.
Unlike those offerings however,
the Radeon RX 7900 Series
cards we're looking
at today come equipped
with DisplayPort 2.1,
which enables support for
up to 8K 165 hertz displays.
Is that even necessary?
Who cares?
It's awesome and it's something
that NVIDIA's top end GPU,
the RTX 4090 cannot do in spite
of its staggering $1,600 sticker price.
All of this is while
actually fitting in your case
and costing $900 and a $1,000
for the XT and the XTX respectively.
That is $200 to $300
less than the RTX 4080
that AMD says they should be
able to compete with for speed.
Of course we won't be
taking their word for that.
AMD has been known to be-
(Linus coughing)
optimistic.
At 4K, it's clear out of the gate
and Shadow of the Tomb Raider
that whatever team red
fans might have hoped for,
the RX 7900 XTX is not AMD's
answer to the RTX 4090.
It's got performance that
is realistically more
in line with the 4080,
though that is what AMD said.
And this pattern continues in Hitman,
Cyberpunk 2077, and Modern Warfare 2.
Well, great, right?
I mean, why did I spend
all that time talking
about the importance of AMD's
ongoing driver developments?
Keep that in mind.
Well, there's this for one thing.
Forza Horizon 5 is a clear loss
for team red thanks to those subpar 1%
and 5% low frame rates, but
also this for another reason.
That right there is a $1,000
GPU beating a $1,600 GPU
in F1 2022 and if the results I'm looking
at right now are any
indication of the kind
of raw power that AMD's
driver team has on tap here,
there is some serious aging
like fine wine potential
on the table.
Of course, you should
never buy a promise though.
And today AMD's best trails
NVIDIA's best by about 17%,
which sounds bad until you realize
that NVIDIA's card costs 60% more.
Compared to the 4080,
the XTX is a no-brainer
at 9% faster and 20% cheaper.
And the 7900 XT does even better.
I mean, sure.
The 4080 is 7% faster but cost 33% more.
1440p doesn't always show us
a difference compared to 4K.
But here, we do see some strange behavior
in Forza that we retested several times.
The 7000 Series is actually slower
than AMD's older 6000 Series cards.
We think this could be
a problem with the game
as it's the only one out
of our suite that does it
and when we went to test
Forza's raytracing performance,
we saw that it was in fact pretty broken.
We also see the RTX 4080
pull ahead of even the XTX
in Shadow of the Tomb Raider
and Red Dead Redemption,
which is especially surprising considering
that virtually every other game
shows AMD closing the gap instead.
The biggest example is in Modern Warfare 2
where the minimum frame rates
aren't quite up to the level
of the RTX 4090, but the
average frame rates are,
which again can set some
potential for optimization.
In total, these numbers
put the 7900 Series
in a very good position to compete
with NVIDIA's 40 series to the point where
if traditional rasterized
gaming was all that existed,
NVIDIA would need to lower their prices.
But it isn't all that exists.
And raytracing is, sadly,
still not AMD's strong suit.
While substantially better in Cyberpunk
than the RX 6000 Series,
these 7000 Series GPUs are behind NVIDIA
by at least a factor of 2 at 4K.
At 1440p, AMD at least manages
to break the 30 FPS minimum mark,
making the game playable
and you can use FSR
to render at a lower resolution
and upscale for smooth gameplay.
But at that point,
we could also do the same
thing for team green,
and the overall story
would still be the same.
F1 2022 fares slightly
better for AMD at least,
with the 7900 XTX pulling up
to within 16% of the RTX 4080
in minimum frame rates and
actually near parity on average,
which again gives me hope
that some of AMD's woes
with raytracing are a
matter of optimization
and that feeling only grows
with Shadow of the Tomb Raider
where even at 4K, it's within about 12%
of the 4090 and turning out nearly 60 FPS.
It is an older game, but that's not bad.
It's just that a good race ran,
when the other guy ran
faster, is still an L.
And ultimately, the RX
7900 XTX just couldn't even
come close to the RTX 4080's level
of performance with raytracing enabled.
I suspect that most
people, myself included,
still don't use raytracing often,
and won't really be affected.
But given that these things
do still cost a thousand flipping dollars,
it's definitely a skid mark
on what has otherwise been a
pretty good showing so far.
And I'm afraid there's
more where that came from.
The professionals who have need
of this kind of graphical
horsepower will be, well,
disappointed isn't quite the right word,
but looking at these numbers,
they're not gonna be excited either.
Yes, Blender runs a good 8% to 20% faster
on the 7000 versus the 6000 Series,
but NVIDIA walks all
over AMD's entire stack
at between 3 to 4 times the performance.
Thankfully, AMD's new encoding
engine helps them push ahead
of the RTX 4080 in DaVinci Resolve
in both H.264 and especially H.265,
which their encoding
engine seems to favor.
That's a good 20% more
speed for the XTX there.
Not bad, though the
4090 does remain on top.
Procyon video and photo
are also pretty good
for AMD with performance
that I would call comparable.
It's within a few percentage points
either way you look at it
and rounding out the video
editing suite is Topaz AI,
which despite the name,
is using GPU compute here,
rather than any AI cores.
And wow, even the 7900 XT
outperforms the RTX 4090 here.
This workload seems to heavily
favor AMD's Infinity Cache
as the 6000 Series cards
aren't too shabby either.
SPECviewperf brings AMD
about as many wins as losses,
but the degree to which
the 7000 Series wins
over the competition is often much lower
than the losses that they suffer
with especially poor results
in 3DS Max, Maya, and SolidWorks,
which even dip under the
performance of the 6000 Series.
That's pretty rough.
Those are kind of important applications.
They pull off major wins in
CATIA, Creo, Energy, Medical,
and especially Siemens NX,
though as we've said in the past,
this is because the
version in SPECviewperf
doesn't support hardware
acceleration on NVIDIA,
and actually this is
just gonna be excluded
from our averages when
we calculate it later on.
SPECworkstation paints the Radeon
in a significantly better light though,
with product development, life sciences,
and energy all pushing
well past team green,
but media and entertainment,
as well as GPU compute
still stay with NVIDIA,
likely thanks to openCL's
relative obscurity next to Cuda.
Despite the blows the 7900
Series cards took though,
their beefed up media engines
and GPU compute horsepower placed them
within an average of 2%
to 10% of team green.
Given the wide performance spread we saw,
depending on the workload,
potential perspective
professional people will want
to think long and hard
about which capabilities
are most important
to them before making a final decision.
Changing gears a little,
we found something interesting
when we were testing Resizable BAR
on both Intel and AMD platforms.
It seems like the
performance improvements,
regardless of whether you have a team blue
or team red CPU, can be
expected to be pretty similar
despite AMD heavily
marketing Smart Access Memory
as a selling point for the
Ryzen plus Radeon ecosystem.
Bear in mind that this is a
sample size of just two games,
but without Resizable BAR,
we're figuring you can expect anywhere
from a 10% to 35% reduction in performance
regardless of which side you swing for.
As for AMD's updated video encoder,
there's a lot to be excited about here.
AV1 support and baked in machine learning
to improve quality at the top of my list.
But despite receiving our cards early,
we actually only had a few days
to test these things prior
to embargo because we
didn't have a driver,
so we were forced to push
our image quality comparisons
to a separate video
that you can expect to see
in the next couple of weeks.
One of AMD's other selling points is
its smaller footprint compared
to NVIDIA's 40 Series GPUs.
And I was concerned that this would come
at the expense of thermals,
so I was extremely pleased to see
that AMD's new cooler
design has the 7000 Series
actually performing better
than the 6000 Series.
With that said though, AMD
does not have the luxury
of only competing with themselves
and NVIDIA is clearly in
the better position here.
Though with that said,
both of the NVIDIA cards we
tested have substantially
larger heat sinks with fan off modes,
while AMD's new cards
always ran their fans.
It's probable that designs
from the like of Asus
or PowerColor will run much
cooler and hopefully quieter.
Now, we need to talk about core clocks
because they're a little
different this generation
thanks to the decoupling of the front end
and the shader clocks.
The idea here is
that the front end will benefit
more from higher clocks,
while the more numerous
shader units crunch data
in parallel at a lower clock speed,
resulting in a better balance
of performance and efficiency.
And you can see that in action here
where both the 7900 XTX
and XT have a consistent 200 megahertz gap
between the two clocks.
And even in a power
virus, like MSI Kombustor,
these clocks remained higher
than the previous generation.
Clock stability in-game is
similar to the 6000 Series cards,
but NVIDIA's 40 Series
manages flatter lines
throughout the run,
suggesting that AMD is trying
to be pretty aggressive
with managing power consumption,
which makes sense because AMD talked a lot
about performance per
watt in their marketing.
And looking at these in-game power graphs?
No?
Not seems to suggest
that their self congratulations
are well justified.
The Radeon RX 7900 XTX
drew comparable power
to the 4080 and this
held even when we hit it
with MSI Kombustor.
The XT was even better still,
staying in line with its predecessor.
But what's interesting is when
we take a magnifying glass
to how many watts the 7000
Series pulls per frame.
In this example, while the
raw wattage drops much closer
to the RTX 4080, when we cap
the frame rate to a hundred,
the total watts per frame
increases substantially.
This suggests that
while the RTX 4080 is able to
throttle itself effectively,
AMD is actually having some
trouble with power management.
And AMD's idle power
consumption numbers seem
to corroborate this.
Where the RTX 4080 idles
at around 15 to 20 watts,
the 7900 XTX regularly sucks back 40
and sometimes over 50 watts,
while doing nothing at all.
What's even more baffling
is that we noticed
what seems like a major
bug during our testing.
Depending on the monitor
that we plugged into the GPU,
we saw wildly different total
system power at the wall.
From a respectable 52 watts
with nothing plugged in
to a whopping 171 watts
with our 27 inch ROG Swift bench display.
Using some other monitors even
caused performance to drop.
Now, given that I have a high-end display
and I live in Vancouver, Canada
where energy is the one
thing that is still cheap,
none of this is a deal breaker for me.
But if I was in Europe where
energy prices have surged,
pun intended, it would give me pause
before I was willing to look at team red.
Adding insult to injury,
this high idle power draw means
that the fans are spinning
at all times, kicking that
heat out into your room
even if you're just scrolling Reddit,
meaning that the 7900 Series
is gonna be a little less
comfortable to live with.
Maybe if you go team red,
you could pick up a blank T,
rather than a retro polar
fleece from lttstore.com.
Space heater.
One possible explanation
for this high idle power
consumption could be
that this is a similar situation
to the Verizon 7 5800X3D.
That CPU's use of 3D V-cache
limited its stability
if voltages weren't dialed in just right
and we could be witnessing
similar teething issues
with this new chiplet architecture
and supporting that theory is the fact
that the driver straight up
locks out power adjustments
below 90% of total board power.
When we asked them about this,
AMD played pretty coy with us,
which tells us either we're right
or that they're not sure either.
Now it's time to talk about
what this data means for the GPU market.
First of all, anyone who was hoping
that the 7900 Series would come in
and compete head-to-head
against the RTX 4090 will
be sorely disappointed,
at least for today.
We saw brief glimpses of glory,
but the RTX 4090 remains on its throne,
making it tough to dislodge its price
from that TI Titan perch
that it currently occupies
as a Halo product.
But while AMD doesn't have
a direct competitor to it,
I still think the 7900 XTX
is a much better value.
As for the RTX 4080, well,
the comparison gets a
little more complicated.
Even the XT model comes really close
in traditional rendering
and the value proposition
of either 7900 GPU is a damning indictment
of NVIDIA's pricing.
But AMD does remain on the back foot
in raytracing performance
and that's something
that NVIDIA can point to
and claim makes up the difference,
even if nobody seriously cares.
It'll take people like me running out
and buying 7900 Series
cards instead of 40 Series
to make Nvidia realize
that they're out to lunch.
But wait, why are we saying
this now, you might think.
We took a lot of flack for covering
for NVIDIA's pricing in the
RTX 4080 review, didn't we?
Well, not so much.
First off, we compared it
to cards that were available
at the time it released
and we ended the video
with a message to wait for RDNA 3.
And we are reviewing the 7900
Series in much the same way.
Second, it had already been made known
that the RX 7900 XTX
was not going to compete
with the 4090, which depending
on how you look at it,
means that either the RTX 4080
is actually a 90 class card
and priced accordingly,
with the 4090 being a TI or something,
or the 7900 XT and XTX are
the current gen equivalent
of the 6800 and 6800 XT and
are themselves overpriced.
Basically, it's kind of a
game of pick your villain
at this point, cuz the reality is
that $600 top of the line
GPUs are a thing of the past
and that was an assumption
that our review made
but did not fully explain.
It's worth pointing out, by the way,
since I'm being a downer right now anyway,
that while AMD supports DisplayPort 2.1
and NVIDIA's 40 Series does not,
AMD went with a half measure
by supporting only the UHBR 13.5 spec.
What this means is that
it can only achieve
its lofty resolution
and frame rate support
through display stream compression.
DSC allows up to three
times more bandwidth
that is both near zero
latency and visually lossless,
though that doesn't mean that
there is no quality loss.
Practically speaking, this
won't be a problem even
if it were noticeable given
that these GPUS aren't really capable
of pushing those resolutions
and frame rates anyway,
but we brought it up
with the RTX 40 Series,
so we're bringing it up here
for the sake of completeness.
It means that those new
8K ultra-wide displays
being shown up at CES
will just barely be able
to run at 85 Hertz without DSC.
But I would never expect
that to be a problem for an actual user.
One slightly problematic thing
that I do need to address is
that we've taken a very glass
half full approach today
and I can understand why some
of you might be frustrated by it.
We've gone
and spun AMD's potential
future driver improvements
as a good thing when
actually they're kind of bad.
Another perspective is that it means
that AMD is releasing these products even
though they haven't really
finished optimizing them.
And if you've kind of felt
that way up to this point,
I totally get where you're coming from.
We ran into some kind of bizarre,
no really bizarre crashes,
and there are certainly features
that could be added or refined.
But in fairness to our
charitable approach today,
AMD is pricing these GPUs according
to what they are now
and their track record
for fixing these things
is actually pretty good
even if sometimes it takes a while
as they focus on new features like FSR 3.0
and the Hyper-RX performance optimizer
that have yet to launch.
And if this is where performance is now,
with some of what broken,
certainly unoptimized drivers,
AMD clearly has some great
hardware on their hands here.
They even brought back the USB-C port,
something that is great
for hooking up a monitor
via a single cable and a godsend
for enthusiasts like myself.
I'm still mad that NVIDIA
removed it after the 20 Series.
so the RX 7900 XTX is
going into my gaming rig
and I'm officially switching to team red
for the first time since the 3870.
- [Anthony] Wow.
- Goodness gracious.
The performance is good enough.
The price is good enough.
Well, at least compared
to the competition.
And the downsides are small enough
that I am comfortable making the leap.
Just like I'm gonna comfortably leap
to this segue from our sponsor.
- MSI and their recently released
MAG Z790 Tomahawk WIFI motherboard.
The MAG Z790 Tomahawk is a
gaming oriented ATX motherboard
that balances value with premium hardware.
It's built around the
latest Intel Z790 chipset,
which supports 12th and 13th
gen Intel core processors
with dual 8-pin power connectors
and Core Boost Technology,
it's able to sustain heavy CPU power loads
to better support demanding game settings.
It also features M.2 Shield Frozer,
MSI's advanced thermal solution,
which offers great protection
for maximum SSD transfer
speed performance.
With integrating options for
multiple cooling methods,
the Z790 Tomahawk ensures
optimal performance
when you need it the most.
Make sure to check it out
at the link in the video description.
- If you enjoyed this
and you're looking for
something else to watch,
maybe go check out
that ARC 30 day challenge
video I mentioned.
Intel's doing some really
good things over there,
but they also have a lot of work to do.